Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Da kriegst du jedes Mal gute Laune -
egal, was ist.
Andreas In Albon
stellte sein Leben auf den Kopf.
Der ehemalige Banker fing 2016 in
Norwegen nochmals ganz von vorne an.
Da geht mir jedes Mal das Herz auf,
wenn ich hier oben bin.
Das ist etwas Wunderschönes.
Da spürst du,
dass du lebst, dass du bist.
Das ist doch besser,
als die Bahnhofstrasse, nicht?
* Heulen *
Fast sein halbes Leben
arbeitete Andreas In Albon
als Jurist und Banker
an der Zürcher Bahnhofstrasse.
Sein Herz aber
gehörte schon immer den Hunden.
Ja, ja.
Als ich auf der Bank arbeitete,
war es schon ziemlich mühsam,
daneben allein 20 Hunde zu haben.
Das musste man
unter der Woche organisieren.
Ich konnte in Zug einen alten,
leerstehenden Bauernhof mieten,
auf dem ich die Zwinger hatte.
Ich arbeitete aber in Zürich.
Ich ging oft um 11.30 Uhr
in Zürich auf den Zug,
um zu den Hunden zu fahren.
Ich zog die Krawatte,
die ganze Uniform aus,
legte Stallkleidung an,
fütterte die Hunde,
sammelte ihre Kacke zusammen
und rannte zurück auf den Zug.
Man muss schon etwas spinnen,
wenn man das Hobby hat.
Aber das ist mit jedem Hobby so.
Für jeden Topf ein Deckel.
Für mich stimmte es, aber
für Aussenstehende war das jenseits.
(Frau) Das ist für Ori.
Das mit weniger Fleisch ist für Ori.
Ja.
Der arbeitet eh zu wenig für mich.
In Albon bietet mit seinen 60 Huskies
Schlittenhundefahrten
für Touristen an.
Aber das Geschäft harzt.
Er kämpft um seine Existenz.
Hm?
Tschüss, Jungs.
Hopp. Hey, Lukas, hopp.
Wann hast du gemerkt,
dass du dein Leben ändern willst?
Ich bin ja seit zehn Jahren
geschieden.
Die Scheidung
war sehr einschneidend.
Bis dato dachte ich,
das Leben funktioniere halt so.
Man könne es planen, wie das
in der Schweiz ja viele machen.
Dann merkte ich,
dass es Ereignisse gibt,
die das ganze Leben
auf den Kopf stellen können.
Das war für mich die Scheidung.
Dann wurde ich offener
für andere Ideen und merkte,
dass man gar nicht wie alle andern
sein muss, so mainstreammässig.
Man kann tatsächlich
auch was ändern.
Manchmal
muss man auf den Kopf fallen,
um zu merken,
dass es auch anders gehen könnte.
Seine Familie ist neben seinen Hunden
das Wichtigste
im Leben von Andreas In Albon.
Aus seiner geschiedenen Ehe
hat er drei Kinder.
Die älteste Tochter Sirin
ist zu Besuch.
Sie lebte nach der Matura
zwei Jahre
bei ihrem Vater in Norwegen.
Mittlerweile
studiert sie Agronomie an der ETH.
Ja?
Das ist einer meiner Lieblinge.
Nicht wahr, Grus? Oder?
Ja.
Ah, Grus, hoi.
* Lachen *
Hoi, hoi. Wenn ich zu fressen habe,
dann kommst du.
Wie würdest du deinen Vater
charaktermässig beschreiben?
Keine Ahnung.
- Was, "keine Ahnung"? Ich gehe weg.
Wenn er etwas will, macht er das.
Egal, was andere denken.
Das finde ich
eine sehr gute Eigenschaft,
die man haben kann.
Ja, und er ...
Was die Familie anbelangt:
Uns Kindern gegenüber
ist er sehr hilfsbereit.
Wenn mal etwas ist, ist er da.
Manchmal halt etwas weiter weg,
aber für etwas gibt es ja Telefone.
Und das ist Liv.
Vor drei Monaten
wurde Andreas nochmals Vater.
Hm, Liv.
Mit 53 beginnt er auch punkto Familie
nochmals von vorne -
zusammen mit seiner Partnerin Petra.
- Hm?
Muss ich das anziehen?
Das ist schmutzig.- Ja.
Da hat sie nur draufgesabbert.
Nur draufgesabbert.
Hast du das gehört?
Es ist fast zu heiss.
Aber wir machen das so.
Ja.
Hm, Hosenscheisser?
Komm.
Ist der Traum vom neuen Leben
in Norwegen mit dem Baby komplett?
Äh ...
Es ist schön,
wieder eine junge Familie zu haben.
Aber der Traum
ist noch nicht komplett.
Wir arbeiten noch daran.
Der Start war nicht ganz einfach.
Wenn du
in ein fremdes Land gehst ...
Ich weiss nicht, welche Erfahrungen
andere Leute machen ...
Man kann sich vorbereiten
und viel lesen,
aber man muss das
selber spüren und erleben,
damit man merkt,
wie es funktioniert.
Auf der Bank kam man morgens hin,
trank vier Kaffees
und schrieb zwei E-Mails
und hatte schon 100 Fr. verdient.
Hier steht man morgens um 6 Uhr auf
und arbeitet ein paar Stunden mehr,
bis das verdient ist.
Ja?
- Komm, nimm mal den Feger.
Kennengelernt hat Andreas In Albon
seine Partnerin Petra Sutter
hier in Norwegen.
2019 arbeitete sie
bei ihm als freiwillige Helferin.
Sie verliebten sich und wohnen heute
auf ihrer eigenen Farm,
abgelegen in der Provinz Hedmark.
Zuerst probierte In Albon,
sein Geld hauptsächlich
mit Nutztieren zu verdienen.
Aber ein extrem trockener Sommer
zwang ihn umzudenken
und voll auf die Hunde zu setzen.
Dann kam die Pandemie.
Das Ersparte
war irgendwann aufgebraucht.
Ui, hast du Hunger?
Hm?
Du bekommst eine kleine Hobelbank,
wenn du grösser bist.
Dann kannst du
rumwerkeln und basteln.
Um über die Runden zu kommen, bauten
sie sich ein zweites Standbein auf.
Zusammen mit zwei anderen Familien
haben sie eine bereits bestehende
und in der Huskyszene bekannte
Rennschlittenmarke übernommen.
Die gelernte Schreinerin und Zimmerin
Petra Sutter
baut nun Schlitten für Hunderennen.
Ja, das macht mir Spass.
Klar, es ist etwas ganz Neues.
Ich war im letzten Winter
beim Vorbesitzer ...
... in
der ehemaligen Schlittenwerkstatt.
Dort lernte ich von ihm,
wie man diese Schlitten produziert.
Aber da steckt
natürlich viel Erfahrung dahinter.
Die muss ich mir noch erarbeiten.
Ja.
Ich hoffe natürlich,
dass ich dann ...
... nächsten Winter ...
... wieder mehr ...
... selber Schlitten fahren kann.
Das ist ja jetzt ...
... diesen Winter
gar nicht der Fall.
Wegen Liv. Sie ist noch ...
... zu klein,
als dass sie mitkommen könnte.
Aber auch das Geschäft mit den
Rennschlitten läuft nicht nach Plan.
Es gibt Materiallieferschwierigkeiten
wegen Corona
und dem Krieg in der Ukraine.
Wie gehst du mit Geldsorgen um?
Das ist jetzt schon nicht ...
Also ...
Das ist schon schwierig.
Wenn man irgendwo ...
Als Schweizer hat man ja,
wenn man wo arbeitet ...
... meistens
ein relativ sorgenfreies Leben.
Man arbeitet und hat den Zahltag.
Wenn man sich selbstständig macht
und merkt ...
... wie schwierig das sein kann ...
Das ist nicht ganz einfach.
Petra, brennt das Feuer noch?
Du sasst neben dem Ofen.
- Ist mir erst gerade aufgefallen.
Komm.
Ich verstehe Petras Bedenken.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Wir haben die Firma übernommen
und es lief nicht viel
in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Aber es ist eine gute Marke.
Mit BEWE-Schlitten wurden
schon alle Rennen der Welt gewonnen.
Da sehe ich langfristig
kein Problem.
Covid und die Zulieferungen -
das kam erschwerend dazu.
Aber ich bin zuversichtlicher
als vor einem
oder vor anderthalb Jahren ...
... dass das gut kommt.
* Fiepen, Bellen *
Das ist für die zwei Kleinen.
Die anderen wollen mehr.
Der 54-Jährige hatte Pech mit
dem Zeitpunkt seiner Auswanderung.
Kommt, Jungs. Nur noch zwei.
Ja, komm.
Von Anfang an
war er mit Problemen konfrontiert,
die er nicht selber verursacht hatte.
Sein altes Leben
wünscht er sich aber nicht zurück.
Hm!
Das ist schwierig.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Da war einfach eine wachsende
Unzufriedenheit mit meinem Job.
Von 80 % Kundenarbeit
und 20 % Administration
wechselte es die letzten Jahre
ins Gegenteil.
Also auf 20 % Kundenarbeit
und 80 % Administration.
Formulare ausfüllen usw.
Das war wirklich unbefriedigend.
Das war bei mir so.
Bei anderen ist das nicht so.
Dann habe ich entschieden.
Ich war schon ein alter Kerl mit 48.
Ich hätte das
viel früher entscheiden sollen.
Aber ich bin froh,
dass ich es gemacht habe.
Und jetzt sind wir hier.
Wir arbeiten ein paar Stunden mehr,
aber man ist näher am Leben.
Du musst dir alles erkämpfen.
Wenn man selbstständig ist
und nichts macht,
hat man Ende Monat nichts.
Diese gewisse Unsicherheit
ist auch ein Stück weit Triebfeder.
Kira, Ruhe.
Die Triebfeder, um weiterzumachen
und für seinen Traum zu kämpfen ...
... nach unkonventionellen Lösungen
zu suchen
und diese zu finden -
fernab seiner neuen Heimat.
* Mystische Musik *
Jetzt noch die Kessel, Sirin.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Eine Alp im Bündnerland.
Andreas In Albon arbeitet bereits
den dritten Sommer als Schafhirt,
um sich das Leben
im hohen Norden leisten zu können.
Kellie: Fuss, komm.
Die Hütehunde
hat er aus Norwegen mitgebracht.
Wie viele da hinten sind,
weiss ich nicht.
Aber jetzt gehen wir mal weiter.
- Willst da hoch oder da drüben?
Unterstützt wird er
von einer freiwilligen Helferin.
Sch-sch-sch.
Stossen. Geh, Kellie.
Jawohl, stossen.
Da hat es noch ein paar, hm?
Die Arbeit mit Hund und Herdentieren
hat sich der Ex-Banker
selbst beigebracht.
Hund Kellie gehorcht aufs Wort.
Da kommen sie wieder.
* Ruhige Musik *
Border Collie Kellie
hat die Schafe im Griff.
Die Junghunde sind noch in Ausbildung
und müssen zur Sicherheit
an der Leine bleiben.
Ja, sie ziehen, das ist gut.
Kellie, komm her. Ist gut.
Eh-oh!
Was würdest du ohne Hunde machen?
- Rufen und hinterhergehen.
Ich hätte zehnmal länger -
das hat man nicht im Griff.
Das war jetzt schon mal gut.
Aber ja,
man weiss, wo die Schafe sind.
Man weiss, wie sie sich
in diesem Gelände bewegen.
Aber da muss man ein paar Monate
hier sein, um das zu sehen.
Aber
wenn am Abend alles geklappt hat ...
... ist man
einfach extrem zufrieden.
Da spürt man eine Zufriedenheit,
die ich im Job im Büro nie hatte.
Sagen wir "selten".
"Nie" ist übertrieben, aber selten.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Dann wird es plötzlich gefährlich.
Kellie, Platz.
Eine Gruppe Schafe
verirrt sich auf einen Felsvorsprung
und droht abzustürzen.
Heikel.
Geh mal rüber und ruf Kellie.
Kellie, komm!
Hm? Komm her. Das war gut, hm?
Die Schafe
sind wieder auf sicherem Terrain.
Es ist mir in den letzten
zwei Jahren hier oben ...
... nie ein Schaf abgestürzt,
das zurückgestossen wurde
oder falsch gegangen ist.
Sie waren heute bei diesem
Felsvorsprung. Das kann passieren.
Ich kann mich darauf verlassen,
dass sie Platz macht.
Aber hätte ich
einen unzuverlässigen Hund,
wäre er in die Schafe rein und ein
paar wären vielleicht abgestürzt.
Das ist mir noch nie passiert.
Das ist Erfahrung.
Da muss man drauf achten.
Aber das weiss man.
Damit muss man leben.
Meistens geht es gut.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Arbeit in den Bündner Bergen
ist aus einer Not heraus geboren
und anstrengend.
Aber Andreas In Albon mag sie.
Auch wenn er für mehrere Monate
von seiner Familie in Norwegen
getrennt ist.
Nein, das ist nicht ganz einfach.
Aber das ist jetzt so.
Wir haben das besprochen.
Normalerweise kommt sie im Sommer.
Für zwei Wochen, zehn Tage oder so.
Dieses Jahr ging es
wegen des Passes der Kleinen nicht.
Den haben wir noch nicht.
Jetzt ist es halt länger.
Vier Monate.
Das ist schon lange,
um getrennt zu sein.
Aber das ist jetzt so.
Andere Leute müssen das auch
und leben getrennt.
Wenn du in einer Beziehung gut
aufgehoben bist, ist das ... Ja ...
Man weiss, dass da jemand ist.
Man kann ja auch telefonieren
und FaceTime machen.
So ist das machbar.
Petra Sutter hat in Norwegen Helfer,
die sie bei der Arbeit mit den Hunden
und den Farmtieren unterstützen.
Ah, du bist hier Mätzli, hm?
Mätzli?
Andreas In Albon
machte früher Karriere als Banker,
jährlicher Bonus inklusive.
Heute lebt er ein einfacheres Leben.
- Ist das auch gut? Ja.
Hier arbeitet man
für 3'000-4'000 Fr.
Vorher hatte ich
sechs-, siebenmal mehr pro Monat.
Man muss sich
einfach alles erarbeiten.
Aber wir haben ein Ziel,
auf das wir hinarbeiten.
Momentan sieht das gut aus.
Es ist kein Schokoladenleben.
Aber mir passt das voll und ganz.
- Was wäre das Ziel?
Das Ziel wäre ...
... in Norwegen im Bereich Tourismus
das Hauptstandbein zu haben.
Dass Petra mit BEWE auch etwas hat,
an dem sie arbeiten kann.
Dass wir davon leben können.
Nicht reich zu werden, aber nicht
jeden Fünfliber umdrehen zu müssen.
Es soll hier
sein letzter Alpsommer sein.
Er ist zuversichtlich, dass er
künftig in Norwegen genug verdient.
* Mystische Musik *
Zurück im norwegischen Winter.
Hund Panderus hat es sich
bei der freiwilligen Helferin Susanna
und Tochter Sirin bequem gemacht.
Panderus hat es am schönsten.
Das ist unsere Diva.
Die beiden fahren
mit Andreas In Albon und den Hunden
in die grösste Skiregion des Landes,
nach Trysil.
Dass es bereits taut Mitte März
ist ungewöhnlich
und gefällt Andreas gar nicht.
Er mag lieber lange und kalte Winter.
Die Natur ist schon
das Hauptargument für Norwegen.
Es ist schon enorm schön.
Die Leute hier
leben viel mehr mit der Natur,
als wir das in der Schweiz taten.
Oder wie man
nach wie vor in der Schweiz lebt.
Für eine norwegische Familie
ist es völlig normal,
im Winter bei -20 °C
picknicken zu gehen.
Die nehmen ein Rentierfell mit,
setzen sich darauf und grillieren.
Das
ist in der Schweiz unvorstellbar.
Der Startplatz für
die Hundeschlittentouren ist im Wald.
In der Hauptsaison
wohnt Andreas In Albon
auf einem nahegelegenen Campingplatz,
um sich
die zweistündige Anfahrt zu sparen.
Das Geschäft läuft endlich besser.
Die Touristen
sind nach der Pandemie wieder zurück.
Die Schlittenhundecrew
ist mit über 20 Hunden
und fünf Schlitten am Start.
Grus, kommt hier hin.
Die verschiedenen Hundeteams
zusammenzustellen
ist eine knifflige Angelegenheit.
Das ist ein schwaches Team.
Nimm den Braunen rein
anstelle von ihr.
Oder ich ...
- Bitte.
Gut. Der neue Leader ist hier.
Ein gemütlicher Feuerplatz
darf auch nicht fehlen.
Man stellt sich das
immer so romantisch vor.
Für die Touristen ist es das auch,
aber für dich
ist es ein ziemlicher Stress.
Ja.
Das ging zackig. Aber das ist gut.
Ich arbeite lieber so.
Wie kommst du zu deinen Gästen?
Wir sind
auf der Homepage von Trysil.
Sie geben ein tägliches Programm
an alle Gäste raus.
Und darin kommen wir vor.
Davon kommen viele.
Und es hat zwei Radisson Blu, von
denen wir viele Gäste generieren.
Hallo.
- (Frau) Hallo.
Wo ist Marius? Hallo. Jo. Hello.
(Mann) Hello.
I'm just going to pay and then ...
Good.
Good. The weather is good.
Das Wetter ist gut und es ist warm.
Sonst würdest du
in deinen Schuhen nicht überleben.
* Lachen *
Okay. Wir müssen zuerst 5 Min.
in den Wald gehen.
Da sind die Hunde.
Good.
Lasst uns gehen.
Das ist die gefährlichste Stelle,
hoffe ich zumindest.
Eine Rundtour mit den Hunden
durch den Wald dauert 40 Min.
und kostet pro Person rund 175 Fr.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Saison sieht gut aus.
Und das mit der Schlittenfirma
lässt sich auch gut an.
Auch da gibt es noch viel Arbeit.
Aber es ist spannend
und macht Spass.
Ja.
Du musst zeigen, wie man fährt.
- Ja, das muss ich machen.
Good. Can we come together?
Weil die Gäste selbst
ein Hundegespann lenken dürfen,
braucht es
eine gründliche Einführung.
Was wisst ihr über Schlittenhunde?
Überhaupt nichts?
Dann dauert meine Einführung
wohl eine Stunde länger.
Die grosse Bremse
braucht ihr am Start.
Der Fahrer muss mit beiden Beinen
auf dieser Bremse stehen.
Ihr gebt den Hunden
das Kommando "Halt".
Doch was ihr sagt,
ist denen ziemlich egal.
Deshalb müsst ihr
gleichzeitig auf die Bremse stehen.
Für die Gäste
scheint alles klar zu sein.
"Halt", bremsen und die Hand heben,
damit der hinter euch sieht,
dass er auch bremsen muss.
Also: "Halt",
Hand hoch und gleichzeitig bremsen.
Das Kommando,
um wieder loszufahren, ist "Okay".
Die Hunde können es kaum erwarten,
bis es endlich losgeht.
Schlittenhunde lieben nichts mehr,
als zu laufen.
In Albons Hunde
rennen pro Jahr bis zu 5'000 km.
Okay.
- Okay.
Der Walliser wurde
von mehreren Krisen ausgebremst.
Jetzt geht es endlich
nur noch in eine Richtung:
vorwärts.
Gut so, Jungs. Fein.
Ihr zwei
scheint ein gutes Gespann zu sein.
Wir stehen noch drauf.
Du musst bremsen.
- Ja.
Das haben wir noch nicht gross
zu zweit gemacht.
Und die Gäste?
Jetzt kommt er nicht mehr. Schau.
Halt mal.
Halt.
- Halt.
Offenbar
gibt es weiter hinten ein Problem.
Come on.
Immer die,
die meinen, sie können fahren.
Die hören nicht zu.
Es gibt Touren, bei denen wir
einfach so fahren, ohne Vorfall.
Break. Ja.
Ho, ho, ho.
Oh. So. On y va.
Er hat nicht sofort gebremst
und hatte einen Knäuel von Hunden.
Okay.
Ja, City-Jungs.
City guys.
Hinfallen und wieder aufstehen -
das passt auch zum Leben
von Andreas In Albon in Norwegen.
* Mystische Musik *
Der Nächste soll kommen.
Er änderte sein Leben grundlegend ...
... und machte sein Hobby zum Beruf.
Er strauchelte ...
... und kommt jetzt - sieben Jahre
nach seiner Auswanderung -
endlich
wieder so richtig auf die Beine.
* Lachen *
Komm, steh drauf, liebe Frau.
* Ruhige Musik *
Neben den Rundtouren durch den Wald
macht der Hundeschlittenführer
auch Tagestouren ins Fjell -
in die magischen, runden Hügel
von Femundsmarka.
* Ruhige Musik *
Solche Touren machen
den ehemaligen Banker glücklich.
Genau dafür hat er gekämpft.
Ja.
Aslan.
Und dann kommen Andreas In Albon
und seine Hunde
voll in ihr Element
und geben ordentlich Gas.
Heja.
Seine wahre Leidenschaft
sind Hundeschlittenrennen.
Insbesondere
in der Disziplin Skijöring
war er sehr erfolgreich
und wurde sogar Vizeweltmeister.
* Pfeifen *
Kommt, Jungs. Kommt.
Das verleidet einem nie,
auch wenn es ziemlich streng ist.
Man wird entsprechend entschädigt.
Das ist auch für die Hunde
abwechslungsreich.
Man geht rauf, es hat Kurven -
nicht immer derselbe Trott.
Man hat das Gefühl,
die Hunde merkten das auch.
Kommt, Jungs.
Jawohl.
Endlich kann Andreas In Albon
die Früchte seiner Arbeit ernten.
Wir merken schon,
dass die Gäste jetzt ...
... nach diesen drei bis vier Jahren
zurückkommen.
Die Mundpropaganda
greift jetzt langsam.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden
mit den Hunden.
Die 21 Hunde, die jetzt hier sind,
machen das sehr gut.
Wir haben nicht so viel trainiert
wie in den letzten zwei Jahren,
als wir noch Rennen fahren wollten.
Aber das kommt gut. Okay, Jungs.
Ah, jetzt kommen wir
auf die norwegische Alp.- Ja.
Halt.
Hier auf der norwegischen Alp
macht die Gruppe eine Mittagspause.
Wie war es?
- Gut.- Super.
Lebst du noch?
- Ja.
* Mystische Musik *
Schnell ist ein lauschiges Plätzchen
unter einem Baum entdeckt.
Doch ganz so einsam und ruhig
bleibt es nicht lange.
Jetzt haben wir Besuch. Siehst du?
Es ist Samstag. Da ist viel los.
Eine norwegische Familie
sucht sich für ihr Picknick
ausgerechnet den gleichen Baum aus.
Ich habe auch schon
am Femundrennen teilgenommen.
Dieser Hund
hat dieses Rennen 2022 gewonnen.
Das ist einer aus unserer Zucht.
Okay.
Wow, schau mal, der Schwarze
hat das Femund gewonnen.
Der Ex-Banker musste seit seiner
Auswanderung auf vieles verzichten.
Und trotzdem:
Bereut habe ich es nicht.
Manchmal dachte ich schon,
es wäre einfacher,
wenn man Ende Monat Geld hätte,
um wenigstens
die Fixkosten bezahlt zu haben.
Solche Momente gab es,
aber dann dachte ich es weiter:
"Wir können das und das machen,
wenn alle Stricke reissen."
Ich bin sicher
mehr Stunden auf den Beinen.
Ich bin mehr unterwegs und muss
mehr machen, um Geld zu verdienen.
Aber ich bin zufriedener.
Ich gehe abends
definitiv zufriedener ins Bett.
* Jauchzer *
Das Glück liegt für Andreas In Albon
nicht auf dem Bürostuhl,
sondern auf dem Hundeschlitten.
Okay, kommt.
Inzwischen kann der 54-Jährige
von seinen Hunden
und den Rennschlitten leben.
Er hat sein Ziel erreicht.
Und das nächste
hat er bereits in Sichtweite:
ein Hundeschlittenrennen über 500 km.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023